three
six
mafia
you're listening to the dollop on the
all things comedy network this is a bi
sexual american history podcast where
each week i dave anthony read a story
from american history to my
friend and lover gareth reynolds who has
no idea what the topic is going to be
about and that is how we do an intro
that's positive
thank you now we're going to make out
great i'll play let's go all right i
don't know if i can deal with the beard
though all over my eyes my mic fell off
i would like you to shave
i'll shave aaron do you have a razor was
that uh was that your mic that fell off
or are you happy to see me
i don't even know is that your let me
say it again yeah is that your mic
because it went it went down yeah yeah
yeah is that
well would i be happy to see you yeah i
can't touch my mic i think when you're
happy to see me how's this for the
audience
are less um
excited you're just happy right so
you're saying i have backwards boner
yeah yeah
i'm from like the planet bonus
where
it's different here when we're turned on
our dicks are limp and when we're i
can't regular our dicks are hard i can't
your earthlings are telling me that your
penises are soft when you're not ready
to escape i can't listen to any penis
talk because i live with a 12 year old
so please don't do it near me when i'm
from planet bonus because all i hear is
boner talk
we [ __ ] flaccid here tina's penis boner
boner that's all it is like trying to
open a car door with a piece of cooked
spaghetti that's what fornicating is to
us on bonus
and called it quote his jam patch jam
pap i'm the [ __ ] hippo guy dave okay
my name's gary my name's gary wait is it
for fun and this is not gonna become the
tickling podcast okay this is like adam
and a five-part confession
now hit him with a puppy you both
present sick arguments no sleep don't
hippo
hip-hop action partner
hi gabby no i sit down my friends
we have fun we like to laugh we really
do we like to laugh um
dave we'll start with my dates and then
we'll do some dollop ones uh i will be
gareth reynolds will be in bozeman
montana at last best comedy friday
november 12th uh from 8 to 10 p.m i will
be in seattle washington november 19th
november 20th uh at laughs comedy club i
will be at the denver improv november
26th and 27th i will be in appleton
wisconsin december 2nd and december 4th
at skyline comedy club i will be in
chicago illinois at the den theater
december 5th sunday december 5th and
then i'll be in somerville massachusetts
sunday december 19th at the crystal
ballroom here's how
you go to gareth reynolds.com for all
ticket information here's how i do those
in my head uh covet no covet no covet
covered no cover no cupboard
well dave um that's how that's so they
went in my brain well that's really not
helpful but thank you uh we'll walk
through our dates uh friday november 5th
we will be at the palace of fine arts in
san francisco saturday november 6 we'll
be at the crest theater in sacramento
december 10th we'll be at the
observatory in san diego uh and then
australia we're not going and then we
have more dates coming up in the new
year which will be the best year that
we've had in a few years maybe
um
so a little shout out we lost a great
american hero uh colin powell
today obviously very sad um
if you
listen to this podcast and you think he
was a great hero you're not listening
hard enough
i better start listening because to me
colin powell helped cover up the my life
massacre
that was part of what he did and that's
how he moved ahead in um the military
sure and then he lied us into war and he
knew at the time he was lying a lot of
people are like no he didn't know
he [ __ ] everybody knew he was lying
us into war we
those of us who were anti-war were like
no those things he's saying are totally
false
he went to the u.n he let us into a war
it doesn't matter how nice there's this
weird disconnect where everyone's like
yeah but he's so nice
and he's such a respectable man
you can be a respectable man and be a
[ __ ] horrible person what we were
saying before is like that it uh is
the bar is so low so low that when a war
criminal apologizes we're like that we
need more of that yeah
but it feels like the show was lighter
when we were talking about playing a
bonus yeah well i mean i just had to i
just people just kept sending me stuff
today and i was like yeah okay i get it
he's terrible
made the case well just everyone and
everyone's like he's it's like john
mccain these are bad people guys we got
to figure out how to do someone make the
case that he was terrible by holding up
a vial of his ashes for you
they should i would love that planet
bonus anywho so r.i.p to a really great
one thank you dave thank you i mean it's
hard for you to be sensitive
i look like i'm uh
uh i'm i'm going going into a surfer
yeah there's you know what you look like
you look like
you look like a guy who would hire
marcus lemonis from the prophet to help
with his surf business i have no idea
what the prophet what is that well if
someone gets that reference there right
now movie cackling the movie it's a cnbc
show it's where a really rich guy helps
poor people it's really
i don't know what you call it
reaganomics the show i don't know
trickle up
you're watching trickle up trickle up
all right all right let's do this great
uh
may 12
1924 year of our lord jesus christ great
great time
and our lord uh
uh
oh god who's the mormon gentleman joseph
smith joe and our lord joseph smith
smith
jimmy smits smithams the mormons worship
jimmy smits right
that's right
i found a bunch of plates jimmy smits
[Applause]
evan meacham was born into a m m m
mormon family near salt lake city in
mountain home
utah okay
uh is this the story of more man more
mans marvel mormonts
his father was a farmer they had uh six
other kids his mother made the family
clothes and they bartered for goods so
she made the magic underwear she made
the underwear and the shirts and the
magic pants how many magic things do
they have i think it's just the
underground they're magic because yeah
when god plucks you out of your clothes
he's like not nude you're not that's
right and then he takes you in your
magic clothes
yep he calls him panties he picks you up
by the back yeah but you're coming with
me you chose right god calls them
panties magic panties i love your
panties nice earth panties
um they grip you wearing
that's god i know it's literally no i
heard it i'm sorry are you up i don't
want to i just i'm trying to sleep
you got on those magic panties from
earth no i'm i'm just wearing uh pajamas
i'm just in the toga sandals got a
little beard wax in okay well that's
what it always is are you having trouble
sleeping no you think it would help you
not on your magical earth panties
no why don't we meet up i don't want to
meet up let's dress each other in your
stuff
let's take off your stuff and see if i
fit in it because i'm so much bigger
wait ah oh me am i turned on
frank is that you uh
frank are you
in my crawl space
this is the lord
frick this is the lord
do you
can i have some gatorade
thirsty
uh they grew crops they had 25 cows evan
and his brother milk the cows every day
uh-huh feels like sinning i see it oh
she didn't see if a lady did this to our
packers the lord would judge her
she's uh his senior class had 30
students okay so
sure uh his siblings had moved out by
the time he was a senior so he missed
his fall term in high school because he
was harvesting okay yeah i wish i've got
i wish i could have used that excuse
yeah
uh i was harvesting oh no problem take a
seat boy well you missed a lot about
algebra but if you were out there
harvesting what could we yeah we're
sucking the wheat shucking the wheat
were you yes right in other words the
wheat was shocked by it i shucked it all
right well i don't see any red flags
here okay we're gonna walk through the
basics of algebra okay this is where i
stop talking and you begin again
okay
i'm out of algebra vamp
uh so
the family sold most of the cows when he
went to utah state agricultural college
because no one was there to milk them
except his mom and she couldn't you know
it
woman's hands are never utterless in
this house
i would just keep them in the house and
you can squeeze them as you do other
stuff right sure you are looking for
like a flintstones kitchen well instead
of getting rid of them instead of
getting random you just have a you like
like if you're doing like you're doing
the dishes you're a couple squirts yeah
go back to doing the couple clearly
someone who's done a lot of dishes and
cow squeezing
you ain't gonna soapy up that you get
kind of a sudsy utter hand yeah you can
they like that they're like a clean
utter
that's the penis dude it's less uh
slippery you brought the men in yeah
well that's okay whatever as long as i
get the juice
and my milk curdled
1943 he joined the air force and he flew
reconnaissance in world war ii until he
was shot down
captured interrogated and held for 22
days jesus okay
uh so he married his high school
sweetheart while he was recuperating
florence lambert
they were married in the salt lake
temple while he was on leave okay his
father died that year
in 1947 he went to arizona state
university and sold cars part time okay
in 1950 with his savings and a loan from
his mom he bought a pontiac dealership
and
a hoey
it's just
like i always think but i mean we've
gone through some but
the idea of ever being able to do that
in the world we live in now is just like
it's like not possible no it's not
possible
and look it was a very small car
dealership it was just like a garage but
it was still a dealership right but um
yeah no you can't do that the native
americans must be so happy with the
testament yes of pontiac yes
yeah we made this car for you we do that
we have the braves and the national
league thank you yeah it's just we never
we never stop giving we are gracious
even in our taking we are gracious
absolutely pat ourselves on the back
well done white thanks
thank you
so the locals were mostly latino mine
workers at the time evan said he sold
them quote mexican cadillacs
sure
okay great cool okay it took me a second
but now i'm fully processed and all
right
he made enough money to buy the pontiac
dealership in glendale oh the big one so
that's a much bigger town he appeared in
his own tv ads he was one of those guys
car dealer in the tv ads i talked to
jesus christ himself this morning and he
assured me each one of these pontiacs is
brought to you by god get a little bit
of god's eye droppers in each one of
these motors come on down to glendale
pontiac we're bigger what's that you got
a question where you said
male 1 that's right he's put a male 2
huh huh you said i'm in the middle of
something right now i'd be really i have
about 30 seconds to cut these you move
you saw the it was cars first thing that
i got in there
and well the ad it was a cars it is
still a car and it got into a weird
boner
not a bone nobody said anything about a
boat we are live right now there is
nothing about a motor in each one of
these motors god has not put his wing in
any of these motors no no no on the
contrary each one of these motors is
filled with a little bit of god's blood
each pontiac comes with the pistons
stimulating each other and they got
god's blood in them that's right you
don't need oil changes in this car cause
you gotta drop a god's blood come on
down to glendale pontiac my name's evan
i had 25 cows growing up [ __ ] this guy
off camera we talked about boners
what the last part
man you really
don't come around when we shoot these
anymore
uh he's very active in the lds church
at uh 28 1952 evan ran for the arizona
house of representatives as a republican
and he lost okay okay
and then he ran for the state senate in
1960 and he won
okay now there were only four
republicans in the 28-seat
senate in arizona at the time okay
wow that's crazy yeah a higher up
republican party member said evan was a
quote crappy legislator okay
so uh he runs uh
so his campaign was anti-socialist
and he talked about a lot about how
christian he was like that was mostly
what the campaign was sure
which is very similar to today that
hasn't changed
um a group of young women started
following him and they were nicknamed
uh machu metz the mechamets yeah machem
ants i guess
he's he's evan matrum so there were they
were called the macho mets that's
terrible i know how about the evan harem
okay that's
the impression that these they're
[ __ ] them all the time these are just
like fans
well like raiderettes
okay
they don't get [ __ ] at all
in
quite a distinction we have going on in
the primary uh so he's running for state
senate in the primary evans spread
rumors that his opponent had an
illegitimate child
what's what you do yeah i just yeah it's
and he won the primary which is a huge
upset and then he ran against a very old
democrat incumbent who was who was he
was like 85 hospitalized at one point
i show him who's got a a group of women
who follow him around you don't you
these are nurses you you ain't seen a
group of women follow to be around
unless you come into my hospital those
are all those are nurses
they don't leave my side
they don't leave my side they're scared
you're gonna die because they believe
in what i'm doing so strongly what are
you doing this is governing from the
left you idiots
now yeah you think you watch this i hit
this button
they come running in you have that with
your measurements
i don't think so i said oh god almighty
there's a
lot of blood coming out of me right now
i'll show you i've never wanted anyone
to die more ah
even if i
oh
[Music]
seeing my
light must not go therefore
must
beat heaven matrum instead lord i feel
oh
i must
take on true form oh god
well evan's campaign started the rumor
that the democrat was dead and it was
being hidden uh it still didn't work he
lost wow that is really like
that i mean that because we deal now in
things where it is so hard sometimes to
even prove these things because they're
just so invented or bizarre but that's a
pretty one to disprove that's awesome
and this guy is just like see
i'm here all right well we did we know
the liar is in the campaign
uh so evan want me
not dead yet
that's my slogan
so evan was john bercher we haven't
covered the john berkers yet but they're
very very far right-wing group cool i'm
very influential of like all the right
words we have today great
uh he said eisenhower was a communist
and nixon was a huge liberal oh my god
oh no
uh i mean there's a couple things nixon
did where you could be yeah you could
argue today evan would be considered a
dem nixon would be considered a democrat
i mean actually a lot of the democrats
a lot of those democrats are on that
same sort of right
yeah right i mean it's
there's some similar stuff there
uh evan took voice lessons to help his
campaign skills
me me me me me a fellow student called
him quote a cold removed person he seems
as if he lives in mothballs oh my lord
wow
okay
in
1964 evan announced his candidacy for an
open u.s senate seat okay wow and then
the governor jumped into the race the
governor of utah uh of uh
arizona sorry so evan dropped out and
ran for governor instead weird move yeah
yeah that's like when someone cuts you
off in traffic and you're like all right
[ __ ] it i'll go to your lane yeah show
you how good you had it
um evan put out put out a f he would
always put out fact sheets whenever he
ran and he would
drop them at republican voters houses
okay
so he put out a fact sheet attacking his
fellow republican
he said arizona had fallen into quote
the category of unclean states of the
nation
so he's attacking the previous governor
and the guy he's running against at the
same time right party leaders are
furious evan loses the primary and then
he supports the democrat in the general
election wow okay
and then he went back to his dealership
uh and he just was it's quite a bold
exit yeah yeah [ __ ] everybody i'll show
you
uh he goes back to his dealership he's
there for like 10 years
and an 18 and then he gets the bug again
yeah and in 1974 he runs again for
governor right
now
the republic which is the big newspaper
wrote that evan now had a toupee and
looked a lot better you can throw up the
picture of him no
um so they're like oh look he's got a
toupee he's got you it's way better yeah
look he isn't looking shitty he looks
like a human uh human person he's got a
okay so he comes in second in the
primary and then he runs again in 1978
against a very popular politician and
this time he uses he uses his car
commercials to campaign
and he'd yell about inflation for most
of it and then at the end it'd be like
get a pontiac wait a second he would so
he was like well i can't afford to
make my own political ads and i
do already have this platform where i
have to make my car ads yes so what i
should do is just do a sweet combination
for too long for too long the liberal
democrats have been trying to give away
social programs playgrounds medical
everything it's unbelievable we need
somebody who's going to drastically come
in and change put money back in your
pockets the problem is a big government
the problem isn't small government the
problem is government that's who's
trying to get away by the way this
weekend we've got the lowest apr
financing of the entire year come on
down ho ho ho it's christmas down at
glendale pontiac i think i'm gonna get
forward
and vote
democratic that's exactly the opposite
of the message yeah no i didn't like it
my name's evan meacham and i'm running
for republican seats again
uh speaking of seats leather interior
don't mind if i do do so he puts out his
fact sheets again um this time he wins
the gop primary and
everybody in the republican party is
just shocked like i can't believe this
guy [ __ ] won okay right
yeah and he still attacked republicans
as much as democrats okay
he lost but it was a lot closer than
anyone thought it would be okay
and in 1982 he ran again
he conceded in a car commercial it was a
tough [ __ ] campaign i had so much help
along the way my wife and a lot of my
supporters people who are working the
phones knocking on those doors
everything like that once again come on
down to glendale pontiac this weekend we
got some great savings for you guys
thank you so much for all your help and
support
so
he wrote uh he wrote a pamphlet called
come back america and drop their
republican houses he's very much a
reagan republican sure and even more
like you he's like get rid of the epa
get ready like he's like that one of
those guys which we now know is normal
uh so
no one cares about him he's running no
one cares there was a public forum with
the three other candidates no one has to
having a question he just stand there
the whole time okay
he lost okay
in 1986 burton barr runs for governor
it's a big big popular politician
the republic paper ran
a huge two-part story on how awesome he
was
and only one man was brave enough to run
against him uh oh evan mitchell here we
go
barr ignores him completely evan's main
advisor said quote it's not socially
acceptable in some circles to admit
you're voting for evan meacham okay wow
he sent fact sheets to republicans again
and republicans this time came out hard
against evan
and barr ran a [ __ ] campaign okay
uh tons of money was spent no one knew
how it had been spent
what it was spent on they just everyone
just assumed he was the guy right he was
gonna win
it rained on primary day
lowest turnout in decades and evan won
54 to 46 wow
even though they all hated him the
republican party now got behind evan
that's so strange so now it's
it's a republican that everyone hates
against a dim and then
an independent dem jumps into the race
oh boy so it's a damn an independent and
an independent dem and
evan just sits back and watches them
attack each other this is before he wins
this this is the president he won the
primary right now he's oh now he's in
the general election okay right okay so
he lets the two fight each other and he
just sits back and reagan endorses him
okay gets a picture with reagan sure
evan took a 300
300 it's me from earlier
in the hospital
it was me ronald reagan the whole time
evan took a 300 000 campaign loan from a
prominent prominent republican family
and that ran out quick
and then a guy working on the campaign
horace lee watkins
said he knew two guys who under certain
conditions would give him a line of
credit of six hundred thousand dollars
sure this is again the christian
mormon character yeah very religious
right um evan then went and assured them
uh their involvement would be kept
confidential no one would know they gave
him a lot i like that he's like don't
worry i'm not going to mess up your
reputation as loan sharks
it's really understandable you guys can
gab about me all you want i want to
protect you guys that's what matters to
me okay
they're developers okay
if you can imagine them being bad
evan's brother willard opened a new bank
account and the two men wired the money
in and then a check was written from
that account into the campaign account
okay and then evan never reported it
okay and that is legal it's
amazing it's not what of course it's not
it's amazing what um
you know it's like
it's one thing to be to be religious and
to be like led by
the
you know tenements of uh you know your
whatever scripture it is or whatever
it's another thing to believe that you
are so chosen
by this
person
in the clouds who has a beard and
mandels uh that you can do anything that
you can like break the laws that are
supposed to be part of
god yes but it's like it's an asterix if
it's like but i will be serving what god
wants so i'm allowed to bend the rules
that's what that's what a lot of them
think right
uh
so not one paper endorses evan
he loved not getting the endorsements of
uh the biggest paper the republic quote
since i have no respect
since i have no respect for the basic
integrity of the republic it would be
inappropriate for me to accept their
endorsement i am the one who cannot be
controlled i am the man of the people
okay i'm not
going to talk about trump because it's
too easy you should only say it now
because it's
really it's
his car dealership was put on probation
even if they did endorse me i would not
be okay with it so his car dealership
was put on probation by the arizona car
dealers association i mean is that who
the hell even knew that was a thing
you're on car probation because he never
responded to one ethics complaint he had
like over 35 or something and he never
he was like you know whatever okay
the independent uh was leading
so the independent candidates ahead
but then 10 days before the election he
said school boards weren't effective
because housewives served on them jesus
christ
i mean what that's like you're five
miles ahead of the marathon you're like
i'm gonna cut my own achilles see how i
do without that
there we go oh that's tough that's
harder he also said public schools gave
kickbacks jesus christ
he was cocky he had that front runner
like yeah i'm in charge
so a lot of people didn't even vote
uh-huh
and evan meacham won okay he was now the
governor of arizona wow
on inauguration day the president of the
mormon church sat next to evan wow good
luck so he's their guy
during the ball evan walked between two
long lines of the national guard it felt
like a coronation
his support came from mormons old people
and john birchers
evan believed god had brought him to
reform arizona yeah see it's it's this
it's i i keep thinking about the
biblical thinking of like
it's such a bummer that the
like
you know the idea is that some point
there will be fire and carnage and all
these things because it's like if that's
where you think we're headed and that's
the that's the end game you're like
excited to get there yeah you can make
it happen
uh
so
he ran on rescinding the previous
governor's executive order
of creating a paid holiday for martin
luther king jr wow of all the [ __ ]
things
quote it doesn't have anything to do
with race or with martin luther king
it
was he's him getting him getting rid of
it has nothing to do with marketing or
race it's just another reason yeah uh
what about columbus day no that one's
great that was good that tease was
awesome
most arizonans were against a mlk
holiday
and evan believed mlk was a womanizing
commie quote he is perhaps no more
worthy or more unworthy than a lot of
people in the country that's just so he
says it's not about mlk and then he
attacks mlk well and it's also that it's
like you know again i mean it's these
things that are when it when it becomes
culture war [ __ ] it's just like yeah you
know what it really doesn't take a lot
to stoke that fire but how about dealing
with some of these enormous issues but
it's like no of course not i'll just do
the thing that makes them be like yeah
he's like me yeah not racist but just
believes that the man who led the civil
rights movement should not be uh you
should not be paid to have that day off
that shouldn't be a day no it's nothing
to do with race no it's just there's
nothing to do with race it's the
holidays
we don't need another holiday i'll be
honest i was unaware that martin luther
king was black i think you know we won
you're the one who's bringing race into
this yeah because i didn't even know to
me that i thought he was a white man i
did too you say that he's well then i we
both i mean i guess that i'm from
arizona also yes so well okay i mean
now that i know i'm not going to allow
race to change my opinion about
something
i would hate that's what i'm being
accused of doing why don't you want the
holiday
martin luther king jr holiday yeah i
won't honor juniors
that's fair it's not i didn't give me
the senior yeah give me that's who i
honor yeah but even then if you pitch
martin luther martin luther king jr's
father i have an issue with that though
oh yeah there's an issue with that
you can't have days named after people
with three names okay it's so confusing
and i just think king
what is this a monarchy what i'm like
kind of going like what
how does that even
so this guy was a king do you mean king
martin luther because then i'm going
like wait are you talking about like
like a like england i'm like kind of
like why are we celebrating in english
so do you see what i'm saying like it's
just okay so so i again i just found out
that this guy is a black man i did not
know that let me just to me it's just
the names it's very it's a very very he
was very well known you didn't know he
was i've heard of it absolutely i've
heard of him and i think the things he
did were great i just
again it's like so you're the king of
the martin luther was like who are they
like oh you're king of lutheran i just i
got that it doesn't it's so
wordy and confusing so we're just gonna
not make that a holiday okay
and um and and and then people still
work you know because it's so confusing
and then i think we do like a simple
day like i'm i don't we celebrate you
know i don't know
like a uh luck no no i'm just thinking
of a person like uh
you know a scott baio i don't know i
mean we do scott baio day i'm not even
i'm not even saying it's him but that's
a name that i go boom
that's a that's a poppy yeah it's not a
confusing name
it's not a confusing name
it's a this is a bad place
well i don't know what to do i'm just
i'm shooting you straight here i just
cause you tried to bring race into it
that's fair yeah okay you make a good
argument thank you
so evan goes to meet with black leaders
in arizona um he's a dick he said to
them quote sub um some of my best
friends are black i mean there are just
i hope that word has gotten out that
that's
fully not because i still feel like
people still say [ __ ] yeah like they're
still like cr absolutely no i go to the
gym there's black guys there
remember romney took a picture with like
six black people and said who let the
dogs out
it was like what is happening he was
like i know what black people sing
high school students wrote him 81
letters about the holiday and evan wrote
back quote i can tell from the tone of
your letters that your studies
concerning his life and times have been
somewhat less than objective
can you imagine like can you imagine
because of
because of his personal life
that that that's what you take and again
columbus no
so you're just like how are you able to
bridge how is how did nobody stop that
argument dead in its tracks yeah i mean
having a columbus holidays like having a
murder rape holiday i just like being
like that's a good one
martin luther king what i don't like is
martin luther king kind of rocked
columbus's boat a little bit a little
bit a little bit
so evan wasn't exactly a deep thinker he
said arizona should solve it water
issues by running a pipe
up from the sea cortez
which is difficult because the sierra
cortez is both in mexico and it's salt
water yeah the salt thing was uh i was
gonna flag immediately but
how great would it be
if instead of the oil pipelines like
pipe three that they're like instead of
those if there were water pipelines that
took the snow it's a hundred percent
places and probably it's a hundred
percent clearly what we should be doing
right but instead we're like oil they're
talking about infrastructure you're like
yeah there's very clear infrastructure
we need to build right now you want to
save phoenix yeah
oil pipe get some [ __ ] water pipes
oil pipe um
so
reporters heard that evan's portrait had
been put over the state seal in the
lobby
of the or or or um
so
they asked the press secretary brand
they asked the press secretary and he's
like that's not true
that that's not a thing and then the
reporter's like well let's see
no we can prove it no no no we're not
going to he goes over and takes it off
and it was
covering the seal
that's a early these early moves just
that moment where he moves the picture
and it's just like oh
huh what are you
okay i guess he did do it is there any
more questions
everyone on the radio and announced
quote the church i belong to does not
allow homosexuals to participate under
any circumstances
so the very next day a good morning
america segment was going to be taped
with school children and
evan and it was canceled when a member
of his staff
told the crew to move the black children
away from the governor oh
my god hey i like hey can we revisit
martin luther king jr day now uh i like
what i like what's happening here with
him and the kids it's great great yeah
we feel like it's it's a good work can
we get it really shows him as in this
kind of paternal yeah yeah it just feels
like around him there should be more
white yeah no i'm sorry
sorry i'm sorry sorry sorry
the problem is i don't think that that's
if i i'm not we're not going to make i
don't even want to have the confidence
i don't even want to have the
conversation it's uh it's bad for his
image yeah no that's a bad i guess maybe
he should change his image that's not a
thing so we just want to get there some
of these kids can't hear you so we would
rather they be outside who but what is
the point how many just they won't even
be on film
it feels like it's a bad representation
of mormon i understand that but it's uh
yeah it's a thing great okay
yeah
okay so um
we're going to we canceled this right
we did okay we're going to cancel this
okay um just because of what you said is
crazy okay it's just
like you know there's stuff people say
and they're you know like i remember him
saying that some of his friends are
black which is you know not true not a
good look true please shut up it's not a
good look
away i again that's not what uh a
friendship is but uh but this is so
really awful that we're actually gonna
have to uh
we can't have you or him around the kids
isn't that totally crazy that is totally
crazy we let priests talk to these kids
and you
and he
were not going to let near
them that i swear to god listen if you
understand the situation though he's
white and they're black i'm very aware
of the point you're making it's just
such a terrible thing that i kind of
don't even know what to do he wants i
kind of
i don't give a [ __ ] i kind of don't know
what to do like as someone who like
works like i'm like should i even bother
working should i show up for jobs
anymore or maybe the thing to do is to
just pull the the bed out from the couch
in the living room just get a bunch of
that nacho cheese sauce and just kill
myself with it just end it all just
because what's the point why go further
why why not just drown in cheese sauce
when humans like you and here walking
around making discernments like this so
casually and unprovoked are you moving
and unprovoking
them or not no not but the shoot is not
happening how much more clear can i make
that there are no kids that are going to
be around you i personally am just right
now wondering do i want to just drive in
my car until it runs out of gas and then
i'll just walk till i run out of gas and
that's kind of just where i'm at because
i'm like this whole conversation is just
ruin my brain like my brain is i came in
here like ready to do this like i'd line
the kids up but now i'm sort of like you
know what matters just being done
you know
i don't want to know that you and i have
the same organs in the same spot the
governor doesn't like it when you come
here and put your values on arizona i
think of what you said to me
oh my god
so
people are already talking recall we're
like a couple weeks in sure
evan hired former
uh state rep john bircher and now
lobbyist donna carlson to be his
go-between with the legislature amazing
that he hires john bircher
and a lobbyist and you're like that's no
no she was all those things she was
afraid of john bercher oh that's cool
multi-hyphenate that's cool
she was now the state leader uh who of
the organization trying to stop the
equal rights amendment
she later said how do you like it's
amazing because it keeps happening where
the indefensible like they're like well
no here's why yeah but like this is like
she's now like a life coach in uh
colorado or something like that
hilarious that's cool so she later said
evan uh believed he secured office by
divine right
yeah and this should be a flag for a lot
of people now one of evan's big thing is
we think that god picks governors and
that should not be considered crazy it's
not well there's a big majority that
want that not a majority but there's a
big group of people that want that
that's right because that's how the lord
works he picks football games on sunday
his day off and then he picks political
candidates don't be stupid about what he
is and isn't uh so evan one of evan's
big things was he wanted to roll back
one cent of the sales tax
which essentially is going to do nothing
for people
but it would cost the state 320 million
but that would take a penny leave a
penny thing yeah we'll never be more
flush with never more well it's not
copper or whatever it is when
republicans tried to explain it wasn't
worth it he'd lose his [ __ ] he'd yell
he'd swear and he'd pound on tables so
he has like temper tantrums is there any
evidence of that if you tell him that
something you want to hear right yeah
interesting so they realized he he was
going to lose his temper and when he did
lose his temper he got his way like that
became very obvious it's good and it's
good to set that precedent where you're
like this is how you can get what you
want
now jesse jackson came to arizona mm-hmm
and he and the girl this is going to
handle the great he and the governor
were flying to a swearing-in of a navajo
tribal chairman and jackson took the
time to talk to evan about the mlk
holiday
and after the conversation he said i
think evan got it i think he understands
you know how important it is
thank you for flying placationaire at
placationnaire whatever you've pitched
evan on he's going to make you feel like
he understood and he didn't
well the next day evan said he was
rescinding the mlk day he officially
announced it after targeting jackson the
next no he's oh he's he's he's not
rescinding his previously considering
the holidays
that feel i was for a moment very
people in evans circle told reporters he
relished doing it because the previous
democratic governor had created the
holiday
so yeah i mean it i
it is this is so
replicated now
in a way where it is just it is
ridiculous it's like how people feel
like things are getting accomplished
by un by undoing it's like well that
means maybe the thing you want done
isn't done but now what's done nothing's
done yeah but they don't want anything
done i know which is not it's not a
great it's not a great uh push
he appeared with a very sad jesse
jackson at a press conference and said
quote we don't have race problems in
arizona now mr jackson could step a few
feet away from me you're mucking up the
whiteness
he said uh he was not a bigot
and these things you're not it's like
they are telling you you keep saying
these things that you're not it's really
at some point it feels like you're
saying it then on the today show evan
told jackson that he lacked moral
leadership
the revenant of the state's biggest
black church now called for a boycott
against arizona
okay conventions and concerts were
canceled and evan was like perfect evan
thought this would be a great time to
ask for a list of all gays who were
employed by the state of arizona
wow
so he well
the idea that he's like boy it feels
really good when everyone hates you
let's start cracking the gays
he said he had nothing special in mind
he just wanted the list
yeah of course not
of course right i'm gonna be a bit of a
gay santa this year that's all that is
a gay staff member immediately resigned
evan also agreed so he he picked an
appointee and the appointee said that
women having jobs leads to divorce i
mean what is going on and they asked him
about that and he said quote i believe
that is a given fact oh my god
[Music]
now
the word pikanini had been used in a
conservative book
and
someone brought it up and it became like
a little bit of a thing and then evan
got questioned about it and he said
quote
as a boy growing up blacks themselves
referred to their children as pikaninis
that was never intended to be an ethnic
slur with anybody
he didn't understand why any black
people would object to him saying this
i mean it really
it's
are these things i'm not i'm not i'm
glad they're out in the open because it
is better to know that but would you not
think that behind closed doors i mean i
shouldn't because yeah like wouldn't
someone i mean i guess it's kind of
trump too because there's a world that
people live in where they say these
things and no one ever questions them
because it's just people like them but
these aren't even dog whistles like
these are dog sirens yeah no this guy
clearly lives in a world yeah in which
he is always racist and always sexist
and always and you surround yourself
with everybody around isolate yourself
with the people who it might say
something about the mormon church at
this time uh i'm sorry uh aaron can we
take a five minute break
turns out the book that had the word
picking indian had been written by
evan's mentor oh okay so there we go
let me guess a white man
yeah
uh so a black house member goes on the
floor denounces evan
evan tells reporters he had used
pikanini in a historical sense
he said i mean you uh there's a lot of
terrible terms that you can make that
argument for with that yeah well you can
use a word
but he's not using it in historical
sense not yet
right
but i mean still to be like it was at
one point a relevant term it's like yeah
okay yeah stop yeah
then he said he didn't understand why
blacks objected to picking annie so he's
saying
he's in historical science but also like
it's okay right
and he was angry quote i'm not a racist
i've got black friends i employ black
people i don't employ them because
they're black a huge hook is coming out
trying to wrap around him as he's still
talking i employed them hit the hook
because they are the best people who
applied look his neck for the
cotton-picking job we got get the
[ __ ] hook around the guy's [ __ ]
neck
oh
my
god
and people are like okay well uh we're
going to take a break
so picketing now becomes a national
story oh good now it's all over the
country good
evan replaced the incredibly respected
state liquor superintendent so the guy
who's in charge of liquor revenue and
all the liquor stuff don't worry i'm on
top of everything he picked an ex-cop
alberto rodriguez for the job
so rodriguez
walks into the superintendent's office
moments after evan fired him on the
phone so like literally the he hangs at
the phone and roberts walks in right uh
rodriguez
get your stuff out of here are you gonna
be a while
and then can you leave the plant
hey talk for a bit and he goes can i
have your badge may i please can i have
the badge the superintendent that he did
did that to you can i have your badge
and then where did you get the
stationary because i just want to change
the header on a bunch of it
so the super superintendent
the superintendent who should i talk to
you before you i guess i came to me and
i need to wait too early to go anything
i should know about the desk any drawers
creak or not just like my stuff's in
there i need to get it out okay get that
stuff out there's a box here there's a
grocer's box i put here about this chair
it looks a little imprinted is that you
you're a bigger fella okay i'll probably
need one with a little bit more of a i
got to go me cushion to it bathroom
again if you don't want to talk about
this stuff i don't
where is it and uh
is there a private open the window and
walk out the window it's out there
that's fun um
is there a private bathroom i get or is
it the public one that everyone else
uses public is it public do the stall
doors go all the way to the ground i
hate when the stall doors you know what
i hate i hate when the stall doors don't
go all the way to the ground so if they
don't go all the way here's what i'll do
and i'll just say this i'm just talking
out loud you don't even need to be here
for this but what i'll do is even if
they don't go all the way to the ground
i'll
say let's make a couple of them go it's
as simple as a door do you have a
bathroom contact number just so i can
kind of leapfrog any uh logistical
problems who's the secretary should i
talk to
no yeah i'm well i'm here it's probably
her
i mean let's be honest we're all friends
here
oh my gosh this is exciting um okay
well um
can i have your tie
so the superintendent had to drive home
to get his badge and bring it back to
give it to rodriguez honey you're back
early be back
rodriguez immediately took it and drove
to his hometown and showed the badge off
to everybody
and that's a good sign right where
that's your first thing to do
two days later the republic reported
rodriguez was being investigated for
murder after he had chased someone
across the border into mexico and
executed it
uh okay so probably while he was showing
the badge off he's like can you believe
this [ __ ] i murdered evan
thought the investigation was an attempt
to embarrass him by the attorney general
even though the murder had happened way
before the investigation that already
started before he picked him
so it is probably more of a tactic to
just
stifle anyone calling for resignation no
i think he's thought of his [ __ ] mind
out of his mind yeah interesting good
good ralph wright was picked to be the
director of the department of revenue
evan said he was quote very well
positioned in the business world
normally we wouldn't be able to entice a
man of his qualifications it was quickly
learned ralph's bank had been blown up
six years earlier and then gone bankrupt
and he was now the manager of a
swenson's ice cream parlor he withdrew
his nomination the next day
[Laughter]
wow
so your bank's pretty good huh yeah i
mean okay well you still got a bank i
mean your bank gets blown up there's a
probably some what are you just some
stuff going on there uh like banks
usually blowing up like people rob banks
but they don't like blow it up you know
what i mean
that's a bad sign when your bank gets
blown up i don't i don't know then
declaring bankruptcy it doesn't seem
like those are in conjunction in
business with people who would blow up a
bank like people are not at the bank i
think you're thinking of another
business banks pop all the time yeah
that's why they're called the balloons
of buildings and then you went bankrupt
with your bank
well it's called bankrupt it's different
it's when your building blows up then
you go declare bankruptcy now you're
just an ice cream manager well i mean
look you'd be surprised how applicable
all the bank skills are to being able to
scoop ice cream into different cones
yeah it's sort of like i always look at
it as waffle cone checking
cup
savings little baseball helmet credit
card and so i'm always given which where
do you want to put i always even say
that i go which account do you want it
in and people go what does that mean i
go waffle count is checking and uh
so you'd be surprised it's very similar
sherbert is uh bonds yeah we're done
i don't want to talk to you anymore
i was having a hell of a time talking to
you and yeah i just this is a strange
thing that you're having a negative
experience very much so
would you like a little
bonds and maybe a checking account
[Music]
so donna carlson thought a few of evan's
nominees to head departments were quote
frightening
he cared about loyalty not expertise
and he wasn't running his picks by
republicans in the senate who had to
approve them okay
his appointee for education was
testifying and said quote if a student
wants to say that the world is flat the
teacher doesn't have the right to prove
otherwise wow
well did you hear that [ __ ] about did
you hear that leaked uh audio from that
like texas teachers meeting oh the
holocaust yeah where she's like you know
so say you're teaching the holocaust
maybe it's a good idea to teach the
other side too
it's like the other i'm sorry the nazis
that's that's what he's they're trying
to get at right being the other side of
slavery right that's where that's going
oh of course when asked uh
if if this was true about the teacher
and student evan said yes it was
reporters heard evan was going to create
a new state anti-drug force
and asked his assistant who denied it
right as evan was announcing it
so he's literally the guy's like that's
crazy of course yeah we're not going to
do that and right now he's got a new
ball plan move over scooter
said he's creating the arizona drug
control service with 200 officers he
named horace lee watkins to head it
remember watkins yeah the guy who helped
him get the loan yeah
watkins uh resigned works yeah but
watkins resigned within a month because
of all the [ __ ] that came out about him
and donna soon realized horus had been
evans bagman during the campaign so
she's
she's like
she's oh [ __ ] there's something wrong
she's starting to realize because she is
as horrible as she is with the john
bercher stuff and the against the equal
rights man she's still like i have lying
yeah she's like wow they're terrible not
crime right yeah right right
uh the governor's office in arizona is
called the ninth floor
it's in a big building i guess um
secretaries treated anyone who had not
worked on evan's campaign like [ __ ] so
there's a
there's a bunch of staff that have
always been there like in the white
house's staff that are always there and
um
everyone in the office was constantly
described as inept including the chief
of staff
one house rep wondered how they could
have an entire office of people angry at
the system
yeah
i mean i thought that was how like trump
ran
uh in the last election was like
it was like what's
you're the president like he was like he
was running against the president it's
the whole republican party now they're
all oh against the government yes yeah
which is
i mean again that is what like when
reagan was like the problem is
government
it is
it's it's i understand why that pitch
worked once because people were like
yeah maybe but it shouldn't be working
anymore
no so evan appointed his ex-campaign
worker private investigator as a special
investigator to look into state
corruption
observing him this guy a reporter
said it was as as if the governor had
grabbed some construction worker for the
job the guy clearly had no idea what he
was doing right he's just like picking
people who like him right right you gave
him money right
or just weren't against them yes men
yeah days later it was reported he lied
about his arrest when he applied to be a
pi in the military he went to the brig
for two months before threatening a
prisoner with a gun i mean like it
doesn't even seem like it's deep vetting
it's not they're not like it's just like
talk to someone who knows him there's
literally no vetting at all there's no
vetting
the investigator kind of exciting in a
way uh the investigator called the
reporter who broke the story slime and
threatened to break a chair over his
head well i think we know who slime is
clearly we know his slime is
and then he withdrew his name from
consideration you violent piece of [ __ ]
i ought to kill you
papers broke more in from information
about rodriguez he had been accused of
rape when he was a cop he broke a
woman's back taking her out of a car he
beat up a man outside
of course taking her out of a car yeah
the murder happened when he shot an
unarmed man in custody and rodriguez
denied all of it he said he'd never been
convicted
uh but he was withdrawn as an appointee
still i feel like he should be like we
should take another look at him for
maybe
these crimes that he's out on the
streets evan said uh he had to be
withdrawn because the senate would not
give him a fair hearing yeah they're
gonna be you know they're not gonna be
able to drop that bias because he was a
murderer and broke some bags yeah it's
like i mean honestly they're not gonna
look at both sides the thing the thing
that i hate is that in politics
impartiality is officially dead yeah i
mean you may as well chase impartiality
the middle of the mexican
desert and just shoot it in the back of
the head execution style okay that's how
gone it is that's right impartiality
used to be the kind of thing that you
did not need to drive across a border to
shoot execution styles
but here we are it is a sad state of
affairs america's lost when when you
take down
unbiased opinions put it on its knees
yeah and put a bullet in the back of its
head like it's a rabid dog that's right
i got you i'm with you brother
well
you're my new chief just thank you
the attorney general what do you do
you're just sitting here taking a crap
near a cactus do you have a job
you're my new chief of staff
so the attorney general was delaying
criminal investigations into
uh just anything because
his office was spending so much time
looking into evan's employees
[Laughter]
despite all this evan still has a very
loyal following of course because dave
god picked god picked him the speaker of
the house quote certain people would
vote for evan meacham if he raped a nun
on this courthouse steps sorry i mean we
thought like shoot him on fifth avenue
was aggressive
who was the one who was like
how can i make this really let me mad
live this sentence up a little bit
is that a shoot rape would be good
fifth avenue
none on church steps
some mormons were now using support of
evan as a test for being faithful
so some mormons publicly said what cult
critics of evan were a threat to the
church
so the church is splitting yes but again
i mean how fickle is your church when
one dude is like the house of god
is that shatterable
one woman asked that the church take
action against a political cartoonist
who is critical of evan and the
cartoonist's father was president of the
lds
i mean
what the [ __ ]
the governor's supporters were just it's
like it would be one thing if if there
were these i mean i guess it's just
whatever your dumb opinions were formed
as a child go ahead well so the
governor's supporters were aggressively
vocal which led to church members being
too scared to speak up right
uh
so
yeah it's complicated it's it's the it's
the aggro aggressive people that are
shutting everyone down yeah but it's
just it is it's just like the second
that you know i mean you you are in
these positions where if you do have a
platform you know you just you're not
supposed to abuse it and it's just now
so constantly abused that it's the norm
but you know at one point the idea that
you would be like
someone would be like but the bible's
the thing that you preach from and
you're saying different stuff right you
know what i mean like at some point that
should happen but instead people like
kill the ones who don't believe you 30
of people are authoritarian or fascist
that's just how it way in every country
this is how it works that's cool evan
believed he had been a made governor by
god sure his mentor a professional at b
you should be locked up well but that's
tons of people i know but that should be
like a test of how like george bush yes
like yeah yes but that should be anytime
god tells you to run for something yeah
that should be like we should just it
should be we should just be like yeah no
no that's not how it works
uh his mentor professor at byu and a
right-wing religious leader said quote
he would attain the governorship to help
america from going to hell in the
handbasket of socialism
and that evan was a modern day isaiah so
you know they are always scared of
socialism which isn't [ __ ] happening
anywhere with the least socialist
[ __ ] country in the world yeah but
it's also like
i mean
i just i haven't read the [ __ ] bible
but i mean i've it's in there yeah
pretty much page two is about socialism
let's go yeah
in the office have you not heard of the
bread tax
there's a bit of a loaf tax we passed
in the office workers who had not
revealed their religion were suddenly
suddenly announcing that they were lds
the mormons acted in unison staffers who
had worked there for years started
keeping quiet around their mormon
co-workers because they were worried
they were spies and would rat them out
perfect
evan had a huge picture of himself right
behind his office chair that's always a
very good sign near elevators near the
elevators was a picture of evan and a
black athlete because dave i really you
know he has some black friends
the name of the black athlete did not
match the person in the picture but okay
i'm sorry can i just jump in real quick
because i feel like you're going to
point to that as in some way
like
like he's
i don't even want to say using but for
lack of a better term that he's just
sort of
that
how do i put this you're gonna say that
it's racist for a guy who's been accused
of racism constantly because he is
racist to put up a picture of a black
man and get the name wrong you're gonna
make that sound racist
okay you know what you need to get out
of la for a little while
okay
yeah sure
um
oh that's him yeah
that tupay is pretty good yeah it's not
bad
did they make teeth two pays yeah they
should do that that'd be great
um so
right so it's fracturing the office it's
fracturing the mormons right which is a
weird thing um
our underpants are ripping
evan's press secretary is horrific at
his job he doesn't return reporters
calls
he never knew what was going on with the
governor once a week he would send
reporters somewhere saying the governor
was speaking very far away but then it
would turn out he wasn't speaking there
and he just
just sent them off
it's so hard because it's like
you're at the point where like the media
that does have access to politicians are
so disappointing that sending them far
on far drives for nothingness there is
something gratifying about it i like
that
like these are actually jim acosta in
the middle of a desert yeah these are
good these are good reports actually
reading one of the guy the guy who wrote
the book that i went office was one of
the reporters they're they're pretty
good um
the press secretary became convinced the
reporters were eavesdropping on staff
meetings probably because they're
hearing everything
through leaks right he put a radio on
the floor and blasted rock music to
scramble the bugs
who did this the press secretary so when
there's when there's meetings rock music
it must have been christian he must have
been yeah so when there's rock me when
there's meetings he's
they're doing it it's a little hard to
have
a meeting right now
do you understand don't worry this is
off the record blue oyster cult don't
worry
i changed the word reaper from well
actually no it's creeper
yeah that's good don't fear the creeper
don't forget the creeper
yeah
it's good i need more
okay let's take it from the top
the reporter saw metal strips on the
inside of the door
so he's putting strips around the frame
of the door thinking that'll stop the
sure yeah because your
auditory senses are gas
his press releases often misspelled
words and sometimes we're just full of
blatant lies
he once tried to leak a story about a
political opponent but was so over the
top the reporter wrote his story about
the bad leak attempt oh wow
this is actually the story is the story
so we're only a month in oh my god
you think this was i thought we were
like
we're a month in i think
i mean this sounds like years yeah years
yeah it's almost like every day it is a
lot longer than it is weird
it does make your life feel longer yeah
right uh
so a month in evan was riding with
police security a
he had previously so he's writing in the
car and he had previously asked an
officer
about his feelings about mlk day which
you're not supposed to do
and the officer said i can't talk about
politics okay wow what a time because
they're yeah they're not supposed to so
evan
now
he's writing with another officer and he
asks about the previous officer he's
like what's up with that guy and he says
quote
does he have any black blood
oh my god which is just a question you
asked because
because i'm friends with a lot of people
who do
i know a lot of black blood people i
know a lot of black peop i'm on a
basketball team with a black blood guy
i'm a racial vampire does he have black
blood i just need to know
and the officer said no he's a
full-blooded hispanic and evan says
we'll transfer him
wow
just because he wouldn't talk about it
yeah
uh he had previously asked for a female
officer to be transferred because he
didn't want to be alone with a woman
do these people sound familiar no no
there's nothing about this that sounds
familiar mother won't let me
a columnist for the gazette wrote a
satirical piece about evan at a
governor's conference
so evan banned him from press
conferences okay
quote as far as i'm concerned he is a
non-person that's it
i mean what bible did you read
what is the i mean
is there a page missing from most bibles
that's like and off the record jesus was
a total backstage diva
god did he hate others
so the press attacks evan because
they're mad about this
so he said the columnist should attend
press conferences again so he's like
okay he can go again but now he just
ignores him okay so that's cool so the
other reporters
start just asking the question that the
guy wants to ask
and finally evan walked off out of the
press conference
and this was played all over the news
i i that's great how do i mean the the
you just sound so paranoid if as a
person in a role of leadership you're
basically going like
is that your question or did he ask you
to ask that question
like just answer the [ __ ] question
later when asked why he didn't answer
the columnist question quote who was he
there oh
that's the other problem is they're
funny
it's like absurdly funny i don't know
how funny he was he might have been
funny it's uh yeah i think he's not like
like trump had a definitely a funny edge
to him yeah uh which was the main
the main reason he was able to get away
with everything he did
it's the like he rode that taboo line
but it was like
it really the way that uh alliteration
hacked the minds of like 40 of the
population shifty shift yeah it's like
that's enough for you yeah it is just
uh so a month and a half later evan said
at a press conference quote you want to
see history made he's now going to
become a person and then he answered the
columnist question
so he's like i'm a king maker yeah
evan decided the media in phoenix was
out to get him
a republican legislature they treat me
like i'm terrible
republican legislator quote this has
gone from day-to-day shooting himself in
the foot to blowing his brains out every
day
he attacked the press so often that the
press became the story also
newspaper subscriptions shot up right
the media began writing about evan's
constant temper tantrums during meeting
meetings and he publicly attacked
reporters every day so
now you are in the zone of like
yeah i mean where
a shitty governor
is good for media making money yeah he's
good for media making money so the media
is faced with the decision of
you know not sensationalizing the
sensational for money
or
being really
straightforward ideally
with media they would just get money
from the government and no oversight
and they can't look at ratings or
yeah
imagine so uh
evan ran on
bringing his business know-how to the
job
right he's like i'm a businessman i'm
going to bring that to the governor's
office because because if you if you
know anything about government it's
about making money
uh reporters now dug into his business
background so they're like all right
let's see what this guy's about uh don't
do that
it turns out he had he had gotten gone
into a tacoma dealership with partners
and at one point he borrowed money from
the business to buy himself jewelry oh
that's allowed that's a business right
off right that's
what jewelry i don't know
a crown
[Laughter]
i need a cane with diamonds all right
and have you heard of the governor's
jewels
this is where we keep most of it he had
also taken out a hundred and thirty
thousand dollar loan against the
business and given it to his arizona
dealership but the partners didn't know
this so so
the partners sued evan
and then evan agreed to buy them out and
he's like okay let's just end this i'll
buy you out but he was late on the
installments and then when he became
governor he just stopped paying them all
together he's like well [ __ ] it i'm
governor now what are you gonna do i
think that's legal
yeah i'm not found in illegality and
what you just mean it's like wait this
is pretty close to when nixon had said
uh the governor if the president does it
it's not illegal president does it then
it's not a crime his second appointee
for the department of revenue uh turns
out he had not paid taxes okay so he's
like i like that about you and his
company had been suspended for not
having insurance this guy's good good
business
the guy who was still running the
department said it was a crime to not
file an income tax return on time so
evan fired him
you you go the you think that you go you
with the bad stuff stay
so good so then the senate did not
confirm his appointee hmm what about
what about it what about him
the one thing a guy who's taken over the
department of revenue has to have had is
to pay his taxes he paid he has to pay
his taxes well i mean not anymore
[Laughter]
so evan [ __ ] loses it and he calls a
press conference and said the senate was
rejecting the governor
he said his appointee would be the
number two man at the department of
revenue so now he's going to put the guy
in the job as number two
so and just tell him to run do it by
appointment yeah right because that's
not yeah that's not right and then he
just like forget the dog up for the real
yeah okay he's now really losing his
[ __ ] over the press in a meeting with
you five weeks
[Laughter]
in a meeting with two senators evan
spent the entire time raging about that
columnist that he hated okay
he called him a son of a [ __ ] over and
over and over one senator quote he
seemed almost possessed
it was troubling at minimum
now no legislators in arizona will meet
with
the governor alone
they're alright that's good we have to
well they're going to scare they're
going to be killed we need a um we need
what would be a uh i guess congressional
chaperone i don't really know how else
to put this we would love it if someone
would escort us just in case you know
just security to me with the guy in
charge
you watch me i watch you got each
other's backs let's go into them yeah
before they go in the meeting they're
like all right we go in there we do the
two and then get ready they're doing
navy cli
and they're duck if you guys make eye
contact you look at me i'll do the same
thing we'll pretend we're taking phone
calls if he gets engaged okay ready guys
we can meet with this song we can do
this okay we can do this
this is what we're trained for let's
so
donna carlson's life becomes hell her
job was to work with the legislature to
keep things going smoothly
but that's not happening he's a [ __ ]
lunatic that's not happening she
constantly had to come up with excuses
for the latest horrible thing that evan
had said
she began breaking down she would now
just go to legislators offices to talk
to them and just start bawling and
crying
so what brings you here today
is there
something to talk about i'm talking
about the equal rights
okay
what is it
what is it here take this beach towel uh
what is it about the uh equal rights
amendment that says
um
yeah but we [ __ ] crazy i understand
that but we'll be trying
god bless okay but yeah but you but
you've
you're here to pitch him to us he hired
a murderer yeah but you need i don't i
mean i don't i understand but at some
point i think you need like that's our
point
here take another take another beach
towel just um it's just that you i don't
feel like you're selling his agenda
you're gonna fall up on the floor okay
well here there's actually i slept here
a few weeks ago there's a pillow here if
you want to
i'm here to talk about that getting a
tax back for a pencil factory
i think i think that went pretty well
i think that went pretty well ah
republican senators met with evan to try
to smooth things out and when they
brought up
imagine like we'll go meet with him
that'll fix it when they brought up that
evan had been asking people to pressure
senators evan stood up and yelled quote
you've never helped me
is that a yes
sir
the last legislators now began
discussing evan's psychosis sure
in a meeting with legislators evan was
told his drug bill
wouldn't get out of committee how did
you know i was doing drugs oops sorry
and he screamed at them he yelled he
would get the speaker of the house quote
because he doesn't have any balls
some in the government started
consulting with psychologists to figure
out how to deal with evan oh my god and
not just him it was everyone around him
the people in his office yeah because
he's interested in these psychiatrists
everyone's right
one legislator quote white trash had
come to the capitol okay
so that's interesting we're gonna have a
trash day because it's not
it's not white trash it's it's people
outside from outside the city
but it's not that they're white
quote-unquote white trash or whatever
it's that they have trash morals no they
have well they don't have morals they
don't have
their ideology is essentially fascist
they just want what they want yeah they
don't care what happens to anybody so
it's not it's it's a but that's just a
catch-all term that people use
right an offensive catch-all term but
it's like but it is like it's poorly
it's poorly
you're not you're not pointing out what
the real problem is which is this is a
religious fascist crazy you know and it
happens all the time now where it's like
you can't let
someone's
i mean just corrupt is corrupt
you just have to judge yeah that is
that's
that's the race of our government i mean
there's plenty of people who come from
rural areas and
and been you know great and yeah so
evans people didn't have the normal
social graces
interesting they wore polyester they
were not smart
explain that pointed out by the dressing
explaining basic stuff to them was
insanely frustrating they did not use
correct english sure they were demeaning
to anyone not in their group right
politeness did not exist common courtesy
was non-existent
they all had complete loyalty to the
governor and acted like a smug clan
sounds like he's god so they're [ __ ]
in power basically yeah right and they
and they hate
they've always hated right this is the
elites against the non-elites they've
always hated them right
inside the ninth floor people realized
he valued loyalty over competence and
the office was divided by religion
mormons thought they were more loyal to
the to evan than others
one of his special assistants a woman
was called the black widow because she
made enemy lists and used her power to
settle scores in the office
god damn
there were a lot of fun
there were a lot of fights because the
workers were both incompetent and
volatile that's a great combo
uh
but
evan didn't return the loyalty he
received for one legislator who stood by
him it was a one-way street when he
called evan to ask for something the
governor would blow it off and call the
legislature legislator quote a nobody
so but there we go what do you get for
it so
hates the people who don't do their
bidding
disrespects as like a dog the people who
do yeah right that's that's the yeah
there's no winning yeah uh evan was
always traveling in state he often gave
three speeches a day wow does it sound
like anybody no i haven't
haven't put my finger quite on it his
wife packed his lunches he obviously
treated democrats than worse than
republicans when a demo legislator
suggested the governor ease up on
attacks evan said quote i just did that
to let you know i can urinate on you
anytime i want
and which is the new bill that we're
submitting for approval
we'd like a vote on it the governor's
allowed to piss in the mouth of anyone
talking [ __ ]
uh i want to be peed on sir
look the governor is now officially
allowed to piss in your mouth if you're
talking dumb [ __ ] so if we all as a
group decide that you is talking some
stupid [ __ ] we are going to what is
called bird bath your mouth that's where
we're going to make you open your mouth
yeah we will fill it with urine and then
we'll put
what the smallest one of us will start
bathing in your urine bath mouth that's
my thing that's our thing
i love it the people of arizona sin is
here to make changes and among those
changes will be the allowance for
urinating in the skulls of [ __ ] i
like it thank you
evan said now and you pay gas prices
said now to to get his message out
because the papers weren't getting his
message out obviously uh he was going to
write two columns a week what's the
message no [ __ ] i don't know [ __ ] you i
guess yeah
so it won't filter through reporters and
they'll just get it in the papers right
but the green valley news reported of
six columns only two arrived on time
and the other four they had to call the
ninth floor and were just blown off by
staffers like staffers would just be
like yeah yeah it's not there and just
hang up on them okay so
yeah it's not working right
now because the state is getting
pummeled over the boycotts about mlk day
sure on june 18th the governor announced
the creation of a sort of mlk day
he declared the third sunday in january
to be a martin luther king jr civil
rights day but not a state holiday
yeah you get sunday off a critic said
quote mr meacham has just created the
state's first non-holiday yeah i mean
honestly like
[Music]
it's like having a national bread day
yeah right yeah it's totally sunday
in july evan went to the western
governors association in utah so all the
governors gather okay other governors
completely avoided him sure
he was interviewed at a salt lake city
tv station and asked about the nba
canceling their arizona convention oh
good god evan quote well the nba i guess
they forgot how many white people they
get coming to watch them play
this obviously made national news
it's amazing because it's like
he just and it's basically what happened
before too where you're just like
i don't know if i can process what he's
saying and you know what i mean you're
just like so you're kind of punch drunk
with how many things he says that are
just
[ __ ] nuts the next day sports
illustrated began running an evan
meacham scorecard to keep track of his
nonsense okay
sports illustrated
yep
the recall campaign was rolling along
they had to wait six months
uh that's gonna be a lifetime yeah i
know
to get uh an elected official recalled
but they started the campaign on the
first day right the guy who started it
was named ed buck it gained momentum
each day buck was gay and the governor's
staff decided to make the recall about
his gayness
sure
so one of evan's staff held a press
conference to go after buck's gay
lifestyle
what is that i can't i don't even want
to know what
now
buck didn't have a clean record he'd
been busted for forging prescriptions
and touching a dude's junk in a store
but buck made the
recall about evan and the governor made
it about buck being gay and a bad person
a guy a guy who is not in government in
any way not asking for votes yeah
they're like that's the story that yeah
so in may buck created a recall campaign
he went on talk shows as did a teenager
named kip shippy hello
it's hi kim shippy
now he's like 16. uh-huh
but he had formed the evan meacham fan
club oh no oh my god no
no you've just been so popular at a
school oh my god
they often went head-to-head on talk
shows so they're bringing it's a it's a
gay dude and a 16 year old evan meacham
fan who are constantly debating
the recall
you know it really sounds like a model
for media
but also it's like again
the facts are what the story is it
shouldn't you know what i mean that's
what is always you
you elevate one side arguing
like that's the point of
the news networks now is to bring on
one person who thinks something close to
rational and then one person who thinks
something bonkers right you get two
minutes and you get two minutes yeah
so
shippy attacked buck about being gay in
a very ugly fashion like whatever words
like you know whatever
i mean ideally an audience would be like
okay so what does that have to do with
that yeah but no instead people are like
well you're talking about
really really religious people yeah
right right so it is it's invalidating
immediately it is invalidating
he was encouraged uh by evans staff so
shippy's staff is pushing pushing him to
you know hey uh yip shippy the governor
would like to meet with you about your
homophobic rants it's skip shippy kip
shippy sorry wow sorry
shippy went to the ninth floors of all
my name's yip chippy and i don't do
things like that uh so he's going to the
ninth floor
he was pushed as evan's biggest
supporter which led to him being all
over tv and the radio sure and then
again this is a 16 year old named kip
shippies the person who they're like hey
this is our joe the plumber yeah that's
right kip shippy
buck's group kept gathering recall
signatures evan's staff sent out bumper
stickers reading queer ed bucks recall
jesus christ
then a gazette reporter went to shipping
honey i upgraded the oldsmobile
i think you're gonna like what i did
i know that's terrible don't look at it
now people know we're [ __ ] horrid
isn't that great instead of people
having to wonder why i don't signal when
getting off of the freeway and i'm
signaling left when i'm not doing [ __ ]
why i always honk and stop and act like
a prick now people will know it's cause
we're abysmal [ __ ]
gosh
so reporter goes to shippy's house to
interview him
and there he drops a bomb
what what
[ __ ]
he asked shippy about his conviction for
child molestation when he was 14. um
shippy immediately said ed buck's
sexuality was no longer an issue and
begged the reporter not to tell the
public wow that's quite a quote
on the contrary
ed had known for months and never
brought it up well he just told chippy
it would eventually come out
wow evan immediately did everything he
could to distance himself from his
biggest fan yeah but you've already
docked the kip chippy
the press secretary said quote we never
really opened our arms to him well to be
honest we didn't like the kind of
chippy's jib to be totally frank with
you the whole time we you know the truth
is that it would think about it it would
be highly irregular for us to hire a 16
year old named kip shippy if you think
about it what if that means to be
strange no it doesn't seem strange at
all well it's not something we would do
we'd find it pretty awkward to be honest
we want the facts and the policies to do
the debating for us we're not going to
put the wind and the sail of some
i don't know kip ship or something like
that
by the way we actually did find a
nine-year-old who is a huge evan fan and
um he dresses like a fireman so we're
gonna call him fireman carl okay uh but
he's gonna kind of go out there now and
sort of talk about what we want and what
we're after what about an adult though
we're not finding a lot of adults who
are vibing with the message anymore so
we've decided we're gonna step it up we
have this nine-year-old here and then we
have a dog
who is uh able to bark when we snap our
fingers and uh he's also gonna do a lot
of the debating for us too he wears a
cape so um so we got the kidder dressed
like a fireman and the dog with the cape
and they're kinda gonna be out there
pushing the rhetoric for us so if you
guys have any by the way again kip
shippy uh new thank you
but fireman carl and the dog with the
cape will now be out there talking on
our behalf thank you so much
we're rehiring kip shippy i'll be honest
we hired kip we'd love him
uh
the staff said shippy always contacted
the governor not the other way around
well but uh that's um
as far as the child molestation the
meacham party chairman said quote he's
corrected himself he's not doing it
anymore he stopped molesting kids months
ago i don't see how you can compare this
to someone who's a homosexual and
continues to be a homosexual yes how
cheap are you you're i mean that is so
like
it's just you are the leader of backward
town i mean when you're like look look
we're not gonna look a man molest a
child in the privacy of his own home but
two grown men come on
uh
so they also said he'd never been on
staff so they never checked his
background again they're not vetting
anybody yeah there's nobody you hired a
murderer they [ __ ] you hired a kid
with a [ __ ] chamo station yes and you
hired murderers also what the [ __ ] are
kip's parents doing their courses were
gonna come out
what are you doing i think dave we're
all wondering where the shippies are on
this
where is ken and cath shippy
so evan finally came out and said quote
it wasn't embarrassing to me it didn't
have an effect on me and my
administration i've never been a child
molester i got a clean life why should
it affect me all i did was hire a child
molester just elevate them i'm not them
but shippy still loves evan of course
and he kept the evan meacham fan club
going at this point is he like don't
help tries to speak for him in public
and he's probably please enough
evan is my best friend
there's not anything we disagree on oh
so at the end of june some republican
legislators formed a group and went
public
announcing they were against evan
meacham
they became known as the dirty dozen
they read a statement listing his
failures and said republicans were
becoming known for having quote a lock
on the bigot vote the anti-intellectual
vote and the homophobic it's called the
southern strategy prick
but republicans were split some still
backed evan
gop leaders met i mean just literally
because it's like
he's a christian he's in pain
he's a religious monkey they will always
get behind the person in power right
that's how they do it
gop letters met at the party chairman's
house they knew going down this path
would destroy the party they should call
it the god
go ahead
the chairman still thought he could make
it work between the two camps so he
approached the dirty dozen leader but it
didn't go as expected he told the
chairman they were discussing impeaching
the governor not trying to figure out
how to get along well that's
we're not going to get along if that's
what you're pushing that's going to make
relations pretty difficult
that's the end episode one jesus christ
i i don't know if i have a enough um
where do we go are we going oh it's
crazy i just it gets so crazy i just the
parallels
are [ __ ] incredible they're already
nuts but the reason the parallels are
incredible not it's not because
trump exists and evan meacham exists
it's because there's a giant
segment of the population that wants
this and they crave it and when that
person comes along it flips a switch in
them it turns them on and it's also it's
also like if you're if you're able to
let the bible justify anything
then nothing is off-limits i mean
nothing the second that you're like you
know the second that they carved out the
flawed leader loophole
yeah you know the flawed messenger a
flawed messenger will come and he will
then it's like okay so you guys are just
it's like any [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah okay as long as he says the right
thing and holds the bible up you know
upside down in front of uh whatever
square it was
that's right yeah that's all that
[ __ ] matters
yeah it's uh
i should just only start associating and
voting for packer fans
[Laughter]
i mean he seems great but unfortunately
he doesn't like the the team that i like
the green bay packers make an appearance
in the next episode
[Music]
you knew i was going to leave after this
one
for sweeps
all right well oh jesus i dropped it you
don't believe in god look what god just
did to his mic aaron
the lord is real and he death chosen
dave as an [ __ ]
oops
oh my legs oh look at that guy he
look at those guys
you